I hear you seem to find a piano wherever
you travel is this a thing you love to
do I've never met a piano I didn't like
I like that yeah that's because you're
good at it every every uh every once in
a while I'll be somewhere in the and
there'll be a piano somewhere and I'll
just pop up and sit down yeah yeah
especially like the bar at the hotel
you're staying at or something I feel
like they always have one yeah that's
happened for sure I think that was in
Austin
Texas yes yeah oh man they probably
loved it oh yeah yeah they came around
and was you know we just did a whole
little show right there what's like a
what's the best do you have like the
most memorable moment Something's
Happened like that you just sat down and
something cool happened uh oh
I was at this party with Anna a Mick
Jagger was there no and it wasn't like
mcjack happened to be there it was a
party we were doing uh this movie Get on
Up and they had a party at this this
guy's house uh somewhere we went on
Mississippi and Mick Jagger is one of
producers so he was but then he got
around the piano was just singing tools
with us that's crazy it was real amazing
I wish I had that picture for you oh my
God I swear I would have laughed while
singing like it was yeah it was just it
was I love almost like that it's like a
movie yeah yeah it was on a cloud that's
so cool have you always been into music
like since you're a kid yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah my mother uh I was a
musician was a musician she uh you know
so she was first chair cello and like
high school and she minister of music
and she sings Like An Angel so yeah so
uh music was in our blood she was
singing to us and playing for us when we
were that's so cool growing up in that
kind of household yeah yeah yeah yeah is
that do you feel like Christmas parties
would when when everybody's singing and
singing Harmony and all that I love that
I know a lot of people that did grow up
there in the music industry and they
grew up with families that were super
musical like that that's I wish I had
grown up like that that's so cool and
just I feel I loved harmonies harmonies
are like my favorite thing like because
I always have to sing the lead me too
yeah me too well it's fun to find I've
always had singly but but Harmony is
nothing it's nothing like it I know it's
so special to connect with somebody like
you don't think we over we we don't
think about enough but like when
someone's making a sound coming out of
their body and like you're you you do
this note that like kind of Vibes with
them it's just that feeling and that
energy is so special I feel lucky that
we get to be a part of that because not
everybody can find
[Laughter]
oh my God that happened to me at a show
somebody was like let's do a duet and I
was like awesome we went on stage and I
was like oh no because like they
couldn't every time I was doing Harmony
they'd they'd just start singing what I
was singing I was like you can't do I'm
not you can't do that because Like
Somebody's gotta hold down I know but
somebody's got a hold on the melody I'm
like singing Alto over here anyway it
was interesting I didn't I think I
realized at a younger age I was like oh
every singer can't do that I didn't know
that
it's interesting to find out in front of
15 000 people
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]